Olá recentemente Temos visto um aumento
alarmante nos casos de dengue
especialmente em locais como Minas
Gerais Rio de Janeiro e Brasília e a
preocupação é que esse cenário se
expanda para outras regiões nos próximos
dias ou no próximo mês a dengue é uma
doença que pode enganar pela sua
aparente melhora inicial dos sintomas
mas que tem o potencial de evoluir de
maneira rápida e Inesperada para quadros
graves incluindo a morte então hoje eu
quero levar nossa conversa para além do
Óbvio eu vou falar doss sintomas e
sinais da dengue mas não apenas os que
todo mundo já conhece eu vou destacar os
três sintomas que acendem o alerta
vermelho aqueles sintomas que mostram a
possibilidade de uma doença mais séria
com uma forma de dengue hemorrágica e há
um sintoma em particular que é crucial
observar mesmo que você esteja se
sentindo bem e seguindo um tratamento à
risca Esse vídeo é apenas o começo de
uma conversa maior eu vou dividir esse
assunto em duas partes Hoje vamos falar
dos sintomas e no próximo vídeo Vamos
explorar a prevenção e tratamentos
lembre-se porém que ao primeiro sinal da
doença o caminho é direto para o médico
pessoal a dengue é uma realidade todos
os anos mas muitas vezes passa
despercebido acontece que sua epidemia
com o aumento dos casos geralmente é
cíclico batendo a nossa porta a cada
três ou 4 anos provocando surtos que nos
colocam em Alerta o que ainda é mais
alarmante é que cerca de 80% dos
criadouros do mosquito estão mais perto
do que imaginamos dentro de nossas casas
do nossos locais de trabalho ou na
vizinhança Isso significa que o combate
à dengue começa com ações bem próximas a
nós eliminando esses criadouros e
fazendo nossa parte para evitar a
proliferação desses mosquitos mas
infelizmente o Brasil é um país onde o
clima favorece o aparecimento da doença
e mesmo Fazendo a nossa parte podemos
ainda ter que enfrentar a doença o
mosquito da dengue tem os seus
esconderijos e preferências eles tendem
a ficar mais ativos e a picar
principalmente durante o amanhecer e o
entardecer momentos do dia em que as
temperaturas estão mais amenas contudo
isso não significa que não possam picar
em outros horários especialmente dentro
de casas ou em áreas sombreadas onde o
clima se mantém ideal para eles durante
todo o dia se você já se perguntou o que
que acontece depois que o mosquito da
dengue te [ __ ] Você não está sozinho
essa é uma dúvida comum extremamente
relevante quando somos picados pela
fêmea do mosquito a egipt o responsável
pela transmissão da dengue inicia-se um
período conhecido como incubação do
vírus que é o tempo entre a picada e o
aparecimento dos primeiros sintomas da
doença geralmente esse período de
incubação ele vai variar de 4 a 10 dias
e durante esse tempo o vírus está se
multiplicando dentro do seu corpo mas
você ainda não sente nada é uma fase
silenciosa mas crucial Pois é quando o
vírus está preparando terreno para
manifestar a doença a febre é o primeiro
sinal de alerta surgindo repentinamente
e alcançando pantamar elevados muitas
vezes passando os 39º C E essa febre não
é uma simples elevação da temperatura
ela é acompanhada de uma sensação de
calor intenso calar frio mal-estar
profundo que afeta cada parte do corpo a
dor de cabeça é outro sintoma marcante
da dengue descrita não apenas como uma
dor comum mas como uma pressão intensa
que parece espremer o interior dos olhos
é uma dor que pulsa que se intensifica
com o movimento e com a luz
as dores musculares e nas articulações
podem ser tão severas tão intensas e
acompanhadas de uma fadiga extrema uma
sensação de exaustão que não é aliviada
por descanso ou sono a pessoa sente-se
drenada de energia lutando para realizar
até as tarefas mais básicas mais banais
os sintomas intestinais como nuses e
vômitos adicionam outra camada de
desconforto impactando a capacidade de
se alimentar manter-se hidratado em
alguns casos a doença pode provocar
dores abdominais e embora menos comum
pode estar diarreia também a erupção
cutânea que pode aparecer após alguns
dias de febre é caracterizada por
manchas vermelhas que podem cobrir
grandes áreas do corpo esta RH esse
vermelhão não é apenas um sinal visual
da doença ela pode causar coceira e
desconforto contribuindo para uma
sensação de malestar pessoal é crucial
entender que a dengue pode afetar as
pessoas de maneiras diferentes Enquanto
alguns podem experimentar todos sintomas
de forma intensa outros podem ter uma
versão mais Branda da doença inclusive
algumas pessoas podem ser
assintomáticas independentemente da
intensidade a dengue exige atenção
médica para evitar complicações
Especialmente porque em alguns casos os
sintomas podem evoluir para uma forma
mais grave da doença pessoal existem
quatro tipos distintos do vírus da
dengue circulando no Brasil conhecidos
como sorotipos de um A4 cada um desses
sorotipos pode causar doença mas a
infecção por um sorotipo específico
confere imunidade somente a esse tipo
deixando a pessoa suscetível a infecções
pelos outros três essa particularidade é
importante entender porque a reinfecção
por um sorotipo diferente do vírus da
dengue aumenta significativamente o
risco de desenvolver formas graves da
doença como a dengue hemorrágica por
exemplo se você foi previamente
infectada por um sorotipo um do vírus e
posteriormente infectada por outro tipo
diferente como o sorotipo 3 suas chances
desenvolver a dengue hemorrágica é maior
isso se deve ao fenômeno de reação
cruzada do sistema imunológico que ao
reconhecer o segundo vírus como similar
ao primeiro pode reagir de forma
exagerada causando danos ao próprio
organismo qualquer sorotipo do vírus da
dengue pode causar a dengue hemorrágica
mas os sorotipos dois e TR são
considerados mais virulentos mas olha o
alerta importante um estudo conduzido
pela Fiocruz em Recife mostrou que 52%
dos pacientes que desenvolveram a dengue
hemorrágica estavam sendo infectados
pela primeira vez Então esses dados
indicam que embora a reinfecção aumente
muito o risco da forma grave a primeira
infecção pelo vírus da dengue também
pode resultar em dengue hemorrágica
desafiando a percepção anterior que
apenas reinfecções seriam de alto risco
a transição de uma dengue clássica para
formas mais severas da doença acontece
quando o corpo enfrenta um estado
crítico que é marcado por uma queda
acentuada de pressão arterial esse
choque causado pela dificuldade do
sangue em fluir de forma adequada impede
a ulação eficaz e como resultado órgãos
vitais como coração pulmões rins e
fígado lutam para funcionar sem o
oxigênio chegando e nutrientes
necessários correndo o risco da Falência
múltipla de órgãos Além disso um aspecto
alarmante dessa evolução da doença é o
impacto no fígado embora a maioria das
pessoas com dengue possa experimentar um
comprometimento leve e temporário desse
órgão para alguns especialmente aqueles
que com histório de problemas hepáticos
a situação pode se agravar pessoas com
fígado já sobrecarregado seja por
consumo excessivo de álcool esteatose
que é o acúmulo de gordura no fígado ou
outras condições enfrentam um risco
maior desenvolver complicações sérias e
olha o problema maior ainda amigos a
dengue pode exigir em caso de febre e
dor o uso de medicação no entanto é
vital escolher Esses medicamentos com
cuidado o paracetamol que é como mente
utilizado para tratar febre e dor pode
de forma paradoxal agravar o quadro em
pessoas com dengue ao sobrecarregar
ainda mais o fígado por isso a
Orientação médica é muito importante é
indispensável em situações onde
medicamentos antitérmicos ou analgésicos
se fazem necessários eu indico a
dipirona como uma alternativa mais
segura enquanto que medicamentos como
aspirina o as ou ácido acetil salicílico
são todos três termos pro mesmo produto
devem ser evitados devido ao risco de
agravamento de quadros hemorrágicos
então Evite o paracetamol em caso de
dengue converse com o seu médico a
respeito muitas vezes após passarmos
pelos primeiros dias difíceis dessa
doença e a febre começa a diminuir
especialmente após o quinto dia da
doença podemos pensar que o pior já
passou mas é exatamente nesse momento
que precisamos estar mais atentos a
certos sinais de alerta
que não podemos de maneira alguma
ignorar esses sintomas podem indicar que
a doença está evoluindo para uma forma
mais grave como a dengue hemorrágica ou
a síndrome do Choque da Dengue são
situações que podem ser realmente
perigosas pessoal são três sintomas que
vocês precisam ficar especialmente
atentos nessa fase primeiro sangramentos
anormais isso pode aparecer de várias
formas pode ser um sangramento nasal sem
motivo aparente um aumento no fluxo
menstrual nas mulheres sangramento nas
gengivas ou até mesmo pequenas manchas
de sangue na pele que mais parece
hematomas ou como se alguém tivesse
pisado em você segundo se você perceber
uma queda na pressão arterial mesmo que
seja leve isso pode ser um sinal precoce
de um choque por isso atenção monitorar
a pressão arterial é uma medida muito
importante preventiva para quem está en
and a dengue uma pressão arterial muito
baixa que requer atenção médica é
inferior a 90 por 60 ou 9 por6 sintomas
como tonturas fraqueza sensação de
cabeça leve sonolência ou confusão
mental podem acompanhar a queda da
pressão arterial e são indicativos de
que é necessário buscar ajuda médica de
forma
imediata terceiro uma dor abdominal
intensa mais do que um desconforto Essa
dor pode ser um sinal de que há
problemas mais sérios acontecendo
incluindo possíveis lesões no fígado
embora felizmente a maioria das pessoas
não desenvolva as formas mais graves de
dengue a possibilidade existe e não pode
ser ignorada a vigilância é essencial
principalmente após os primeiros dias de
sintomas quando a febre começa a baixar
É nesse momento que os sinais de alerta
de complicações sérias como queda de
pressão
arterial sangramentos anormais e dor
abdominal intensa eles devem ser
monitorados de perto tenha medidor de
pressão em casa monitore a sua pressão
ou de seu familiar com relação a
sintomas e observações como as que eu
expliquei nesse vídeo a rapidez com que
a dengue pode se agravar mostra pra
gente a importância de buscar
atendimento médico imediato ao primeiro
sinal de complicações não perca a
segunda parte desse assunto onde eu vou
falar com vocês vou conversar sobre a
prevenção e tratamento da dengue Muito
obrigado pela sua atenção um grande
abraço um beijo no seu coração e você é
feira